Welcome to the session on genetics and environmental determinants of
cancer. Thanks for staying until almost the last
session and coming to hear the talks.
I'm Nuria López-Bigas. I'm a professor at the Institute of Research
in Biomedicine in Barcelona,
and it's my pleasure to chair this session.
So in this session, we are going to talk about
how every one of us, it's a different risk of developing cancer
and how cancer develops as well differently,
due to different determinants, which are genetic determinants, but also
lifestyle exposures that may modify our
risk of developing cancer. And we have
three amazing speakers and then also myself.
So I'm going to do a very quick introduction of the speakers so that then we go
directly from one presentation to the other.
So we are going to have first Kamila Axelrod, who is a professor of
genetics at Harvard Medical School.
She's a thought leader on cancer genetics, cancer
evolution. She has done a lot of theoretical and
computational work, and she's going to talk about distinguishing
selection in normal tissues from cancer causation.
Next, we are going to have Professor Alan Balmain.
He's
UCSF from University of California, San Francisco,
and he works at the Helen Diller Family Comprehensive Cancer Center.
And he's a professor on genetics, and
many of you may know him. He has done seminal work on tumor
promotion, especially
using mouse models,
to understand this relationship between exposure and environmental
carcinogens.
We'll have also Jian Carrot Zhang.
He is an assistant member in the computational oncology
service at the Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center.
His research focus on elucidating the germline somatic
interactions across multi-ancestral populations.
He's doing basically computational work.
And
the abstract was selected abstract, so
congratulations, Jian.
We heard that he's going to talk about unpublished work that we are all very
excited about to hear. And the last talk is going to be by
myself
on cancer driver mutations in normal tissues and its relation to cancer risk.
So the way it's going to work, we are going to have a 15 minutes presentation,
followed by five minutes questions after each presentation.
And at the end, we may still have a bit more of time for a panel discussion
or questions addressed to all of us.
So with any further ado, we'll welcome at the stage Kamila
Axelrod. And yeah, floor is yours.
Great. Thank you so much, everybody, for sticking out with us
here. We were just saying among the speakers that this is the audience we want, the
really committed ones who are here to the last moment.
So thank you for that. And yeah, I'll get us started.
I'll talk about a question that hopefully some of you will find interesting and
maybe a little bit provocative, namely,
what do we really know about the mutations that we have found to
be enriched in cancer genomes? Are those necessarily mutations
that cause cancer, or are maybe some of them just an inheritance from the normal
tissue evolution that precedes carcinogenesis as we age?
So which mutations cause cancer? Seems like a very simple
question. And of course, through big cancer genome sequencing efforts
like the TCGA, PEACOCK, and many others that you're familiar
with, you'll know that we have very good, robust methods for
identifying cancer drivers. Many variations of them
are available, but typically, the approach is something like we
sequence a whole bunch of cancers from the same tissue.
We look at the variants found in an individual gene.
Some of them are synonymous mutations that don't cause any protein changes.
Some of them are non-synonymous mutations that do change the protein.
And we look at their relative ratios and really conclude that
if a gene is enriched for mutations that change its function, then
this gene is likely to be a cancer-causing gene.
So mutations in gene X, they occur frequently or show signs
of positive selection. We conclude that they cause cancer.
However, one of the big conceptual, I will say,
remodelings that has taken place in the last 10 to 15 years
is that we've come to understand that the tissues in our
bodies contain lots and lots of cells that contain ample mutations
that were previously thought to be more specific to the cancer than they really
are. So mutations arise during somatic evolution all the
time. They arise during embryonic development.
They arise as our cells turn over for the homeostasis of our
tissues. And then some of the mutations that occur in our cells, if
they confer a competitive advantage to the cell, can expand
and form this now famous patchwork of mutant clones that
inhabits most of the self-renewing tissues that
we have in our body. And of course, a big topic of the session today,
we think that the structure of these clones, the frequency of the mutations
that are sitting in these clones really affect our risk of
getting cancer down the line. And of course, when the cancer then
emerges from one of these
background mutant clones that are sitting
everywhere,
it's not only characterized by the mutations that really make it into a cancer, but
it inherits all the mutations that were sometimes maybe
innocently
acquired during this normal tissue evolution process.
So what we now have to ask is, do signals of positive selections in cancer
genomes reflect cancer causation necessarily, or are
some of them may be merely an inheritance from normal tissue
evolution?So you can think of it as
a Venn diagram like this. There is going to be mutations that are positively
selected in our normal tissues, and there's going to be mutations that cause
cancer. Without a doubt, there will be a significant overlap.
But how large the overlap is and in which of these categories
any one individual mutation belongs is an open question and I think an exciting
question.
So, a postdoc in my lab who is a formal
mathematician and a probabilist started thinking about
a rigorous way of trying to incorporate the data that we currently have to answer
the question of, if we find a mutation in the cancer genome, can we figure out
whether it's
really a mutation that is selected during normal tissue evolution, or is it
cancer-causing?
And so the first thing that we have to do is to come up with a definition of
carcinogenicity.
A true probabilist thinks of this definition as
a ratio of rates. So it's actually really simple.
Think of a cell that has a particular mutation Z, your favorite mutation, you can
think of it right now,
and this cell causes a transformation
into a lineage that will eventually be diagnosed as a cancer.
At the same time, there is a cell without this mutation Z, and this cell can of
course also cause cancer for whatever reason,
but it's going to do this at a different rate, R0.
And so we think of the mutation Z's carcinogenic effect as really just the ratio
between the rate R1 and R0. So how much more likely is a
cell that carries the mutation to found a truly malignant lineage
over a cell that doesn't have the mutation?
The nice thing about this carcinogenic effect is that it's really easy to
estimate from data. We really need only two things for it.
So we need Y, the frequency of the mutation among cancers
of that type, and sorry, I just see people taking pictures.
This is all on bioRxiv. Of course, you're still welcome to take as many pictures as
you like, but all of this is on bioRxiv, and the paper is actually in press as
well. It's about to come out in "Nature Genetics" within the next few weeks.
So,
just to make life easier for you .
So yes, we only need two things. So we need Y, the frequency of the
mutation among cancers of that type. So let's walk through an example.
Let's say we care about esophageal squamous cell carcinoma.
We can go into TCGA or Peacock, and then for mutations
that are frequently found to be mutated in esophageal squamous cell carcinoma, we
can look at the frequency. So how many cancers of that type carry that
mutation? Which, for example, for P53 is around 80.
Now we need X, the frequency of the mutation among normal
cells in the same tissue of origin, ideally in the same
patients. So we'll talk about this more in just a moment.
But this data has for a long time not been available.
It is now more and more being generated for various tissues, which is a wonderful
thing. So for the esophagus, there's an excellent set of papers.
Actually, I'm just quoting one here, where investigators have gone in
here from Seishi Ogawa's group in Japan, and they have deep
sequenced a very small biopsy of the normal esophageal
mucosa
from people who also had surgery for esophageal cancer and
basically genotyped these cells to look at what the frequency of these
mutations in the normal tissue is that didn't give rise to the cancer and also has
no clonal relationship to the cancer that arose.
And so once we have these two frequencies, we can project mutations into this
space,
which is interesting to look at because it classifies mutations
as strongly carcinogenic, meaning that they're much more likely to be found in a
cancer of a particular type, but much less likely in the corresponding normal
tissue, or cancer inhibiting, which means that even
though all the genes that we're considering here are bona fide esophageal
squamous cell carcinoma drivers as defined by TCGA, they may, in
some cases, actually be mutated more frequently in the normal tissue
than in the corresponding cancer, which would make them cancer inhibiting, kind
of really turning the world upside down for a cancer
geneticist. And then the carcinogenic effect estimate is really just the odds ratio
of these frequencies. So let's do it.
Let's actually put the genes in this space.
You will see some that are entirely
unsurprising. So for example, P53
is coming out with carcinogenic effect standing in the thousands, meaning that
it's much, much more frequent in esophageal squamous cell carcinoma than in the
corresponding
normal cells in the esophagus.
However, on the other side, we also have other examples that now at this
point, a famous notch one, which we've for a long time considered to be a
strong driver of esophageal squamous cell carcinoma because it's so frequently
mutated in that cancer. But this type of sequencing has now shown
us that while it's actually even more frequent in the normal esophagus,
and we have to kind of reclassify it now as tumor formation inhibiting.
And there are some really great experiments from Phil Jones' lab that
have experimentally corroborated the tumor inhibiting function
of notch mutations. And then maybe to me, most
interesting is this line one here.
That's carcinogenic effect one. That means those mutations or mutations in
those genes, according to this analysis, have very little effect on the
probability of a cell becoming malignant.
And there are some pretty famous cancer drivers here, including PIK3CA,
FAD1, EP300.
I'm going to talk about some of them, in particular PIK3CA,
in more depth.
But really what it means is that these mutations are no more frequent in the cancer
than they would be in the corresponding normal tissue,
really
at least at the most
naive interpretation, inconsistent with a strong carcinogenic effect of
PIK3CA.
So we can do this for other organs now.
Here is just an example from the blood
where you can again see that some mutations have extremely large
carcinogenic effects. They very frequently occur in AML, but almost never
in the normal blood. But then some of the most frequent mutations that are found
in AML, including TET2 and DNMT3A, SXL1,
you see that they have relatively low carcinogenic effects and actually don't
really do much to lineage in terms of pushing it in the direction of
AML.Very briefly, just in case you're wondering, we compared our
carcinogenic effects to independent estimates of AML
risk of people who had blood sample taken, and then later
years down the line, they developed AML, and there's a great paper
by Gu et al. that calculated hazard ratios for a number
of genes based on these data, and they
agree really well with what we get with carcinogenic effects estimates,
except that we didn't have to go through the trouble of looking
for these rare samples where you have pre-AML blood and then the
corresponding cancer. So that's kind of neat.
However, and so this very much speaks to the topic of this
session here, namely genetic and environmental
risks for cancer development.
There's one thing that is
making this analysis a little bit difficult, and that is that in order to
do it properly, you really need normal tissue data
from the same people that you analyze the cancers of. Why is that?
Well, it's because selective pressures on our tissues, and
therefore the clonal evolution of our tissues, can really vary very much from
person to person, and presumably the cancer risk that goes with
that variant
is quite different as well. So germline variants,
lifestyle factors like what you eat, what you drink, medical history,
whether you've had chemotherapy or not, all of these factors profoundly
affect how your normal tissues will evolve.
They will change the frequency of cancer driving
mutations in your tissues. And so in order to get a fair comparison, we really
need normal tissue sequencing data from the same people
that we get the cancers from. So that
would be the ideal world. Really, really hard to obtain.
So what David wanted to know was, can we actually identify carcinogenic
mutations from cancer genomes alone without having to go and collect the
corresponding normal tissue? And when he first posed this question, I thought,
"No, of course, we can't. What are you even talking about?" But again, he's a
mathematician. He thinks very differently, and he proposed what I think is
a really amazing way to try and do this.
And so in order to just briefly explain to you the concept,
bear with me for a moment and let's just imagine what is a mutation that doesn't
cause cancer but is positively selected in normal tissues behave like over a
human lifetime? So what you can see here is that this mutation,
if it confers a selective advantage to the cell that it has, will
expand in our tissues as we age.
The form of the expansion, unknown. It could be exponential.
It could be less than exponential.
But basically, because the mutant cell needs
time to multiply itself,
it's
much more likely to find it at high frequencies in older people than in young
people. Another way of saying it is, in young people, evolution hasn't had time to
act on the mutations that are present, and so
we typically wouldn't think of
big expansion of
mutations with selective advantages in young people.
So the corollary is that if we look at the
expected fraction of cancers with this mutation Z,
it should be enriched in older people simply because evolution has acted in older
people.
But if you think about a mutation that has a strong carcinogenic effect, it looks
very different. This curve looks very different.
In young people,
evolution hasn't had time to act on our normal tissue, so any mutations
that you see at high frequency in young people and they are under positive
selection are much more likely to be carcinogenic.
And so,
yeah, I'll just in the last two minutes walk you through a brief example, which is
AML, to really just try to test this hypothesis.
The hypothesis is if a mutation is under selection by
GNds, for example, and it's enriched in younger people, we can pretty
confidently say that the null hypothesis of it not being
cancer-causing can be rejected.
So here we see that in AML, mutations actually have very different age
distributions. Some are much more likely to happen in young people, and some much
more likely to happen in older patients.
And so our hypothesis is that this is due to the interaction of normal tissue
evolution and carcinogenesis. Age-varying biology can very much be a part of this.
There is no contradiction here. I'll briefly comment
on this in just a moment, but
if you now look at the mutations
and how frequently they occur in young onset AML, so in young people who get
AML versus older people with AML, you see that there's basically no
correlation. People with young and old onset AML have very different mutation
patterns. However, if you transform this into carcinogenic
effects, meaning that you normalize
the frequency at which the mutations occur in older people by the
corresponding
evolution and known selective effects
of these mutations in the blood, you see that all of a sudden these things do line
up. So normalizing for normal tissue evolution actually makes the carcinogenic
effects line up between young and older
onset
AML. And so this is really interesting because it suggests that the age-varying
biology is maybe not as strong as people have thought.
I'm happy to discuss this in more depth after the session because I know this is a
complicated plot and there's not that much time.
But I'll just say that we see the same thing for many other cancer types,
that where we can correlate carcinogenic effect estimates, we see that
they appear to correlate
extremely well with age and that those mutations that
are preferentially found in
younger people tend to be the ones with very high carcinogenic effects.
And, yeah, maybe just as the last point, even if you don't have any normal tissue
sequencing data, just looking at mutations that are preferentially mutated in
younger people, this is now in breast cancer,
but we have
this type of plot for really every cancer type and every subset of breast cancer
that you can imagine. It always looks the same.Really highlight some genes
that we are pretty sure are carcinogenic, while
others like PIK3CA, the jury is still out. All right.
So I'll just summarize here. Positive selection normal tissues can
distort our view of cancer causation, but we think that with the right normal
tissue sequencing data, we can really get a clearer view, and if we
don't have that data, then age data is super helpful
because genes that are frequency mutated in younger cancer
patients are very likely to be causal. And so here's this paper.
Again, this is in press, so it will be coming out any time anyway.
But please go to bioRxiv and take a look, and this is David,
the mastermind
behind this project. Thank you for your attention.
Questions?
Thanks for a super talk. Alistair Lamb, London.
I manage and investigate prostate cancer and
thank you for explaining so clearly a potential explanation for
what we think we're seeing in prostate cancer, which is
somatic mosaicism in
normal untransformed tissue in an otherwise slow
growing,
quite indolent
epithelial
organ. I just wonder whether you've had a chance to think
about... You mentioned breast cancer,
but could this paradigm explain
how the sort of latent effects of maybe somatic events
occurring in puberty could lead to
a potentially nasty cancer in your 50s and 60s?
Yeah. Prostate is such an interesting organ.
I'm not aware of a good prostate normal tissue sequencing
study. If somebody is, I would definitely love to see it.
I do think, kind of going back to the theme of this session,
whatever happens to your tissues and in particular your reproductive
tissues in puberty is hugely important
because it sets up, so to speak, the clonal patchwork that then
keeps evolving for the rest of your life.
So if through some event in puberty
you have
particular mutations expanding that carry high cancer risk, this could really
change
your
risk down the line. It's the same in breast cancer famously.
Just the number of menstrual cycles that a woman go through is correlated
with the risk of breast cancer and that probably has much to do with the clonal
evolution that's driven by every cycle.
Cell death and regeneration give the opportunity for clones to expand
and show that they have a selective advantage, so to speak.
So I think that paradigm is universal and would apply to the prostate as well.
Thanks.
Yeah. Thanks.
Great talk. I had a question about the figures you were showing with
the green to gray gradient where you're showing mutation frequency in the
pre-malignancy versus the malignancy.
You mentioned right at the beginning how both
the mutation frequency matters, but also the selection.
Could you just comment a little bit on how we can maybe infer a
selection from those plots of mutation frequency?
Or how to separate those out?
Yes. So
are you asking specifically about the role of mutagenesis versus
selection?
Am I understanding the question correctly?
Yeah, I think so.
They both contribute
to these plots. So the plots show the frequency of the mutation in the
normal tissue and in the corresponding cancer.
Frequency can be high because of high mutagenesis, or the frequency can be high due
to selection. The plots themselves cannot disentangle that.
And actually, it is something that in the cancer field I think
people should be thinking more about.
Whenever they see mutations occurring, the question always is, "Oh, there must be
elevated mutagenesis." That's not the case.
Selection is a potentially much, much more potent factor in
causing high frequency mutations in our tissues.
But because it is without additional
information not trivial to distinguish mutagenesis from selection,
a simple plot like that can't disentangle it.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Hi.
Thank you. So this model, to me it
looks really like linear model, right?
Like one mutation,
cancer development or causation or not.
What if you have the effect of different
mutation that it's coupled, then maybe it can induce cancer or
not. Can you detect it with your model?
This model is not in any way a one-stage model.
We're looking in a simplified way on the mutation
frequencies of one gene at a time,
but all of that I've been showing you is entirely consistent with a traditional
multistage carcinogenesis model.
And this is formally covered in the paper if you're interested in it, but
essentially,
if you have a cancer-causing mutation occurring, that's the first step on the
way to cancer, and it generally elevates your probability of completing
the rest of the steps. So these things,
they don't have a one-to-one correspondence, but that they're very much correlated.
So if you have massive expansion of a cancer-causing mutation in the
tissue, even though that mutation alone is of course not sufficient to give you
cancer, it elevates your risk that one of these lineages will
then go the additional second, third and fourth step, however many you
believe there are,
and so there's a really good correspondence.
Thank you.
Okay. Thanks-
Thank you so much
... a lot.
Thank you.
Next speaker is Alan Balmain.
While he prepares, I'm going to remind everyone that we can also take
questions from people that is watching online.
So just feel free to ask questions and I'll be monitoring if they
are here.
Okay. Thank you, Nuria,
for the introduction and the previous speaker for setting up
many of the questions that I'm going to be
talking about from a somewhat different direction.
So first of all, the funding comes from Cancer Grand
Challenges program.
I see several representatives here at the front,
who've made huge contributions to what I'm
going to talk to you about.
So the issue of clonal evolution really,
I think has been around for a long time, but it came to the fore in the last
10 years probably,
with some of the papers are shown here.
But
this famous picture on the right showing these clones that
evolve during aging and we're basically a mosaic of
nasty looking clones from rather a young age.
This, of course,
as many things that are discovered, had been seen
previously. So these are clones in mouse skin that were
found by the De Gruijff group in
Holland,
in the '90s. Clones with p53 mutations and otherwise
pretty normal architecture.
Also seen in humans within Doug Brash's group.
P53 clones clearly are in the normal tissue, and they sit
there. They don't have any obvious pathology but can
clearly contribute to what was thought as
or described as field effects leading to carcinogenesis.
We can go back even further to the 1940s and these experiments
done on mouse skin carcinogenesis induced by initiators and
promoters also suggested that there are clones that have to
be long-lived, in normal tissue. And that was shown by this experiment
here. So these top lines, many of you I'm sure are familiar with a lot of this.
The initial experiment showing initiation
by a mutagen, at least what turned out to be a mutagen that doesn't give
any tumors. Inflammation does not give any tumors, but the one
followed by the other gives lots of tumors and leads to the death of the mice.
So this was the first demonstration of multi-stage carcinogenesis.
But the important point is this one here.
What they showed back in the '40s is that the first step, the
initiating step, which they said was a mutagen, mutagenic step,
although they didn't really have any evidence at that time,
that that was permanent. So once that event takes place,
you can wait till the mouse is almost dead and then begin the inflammation, and
the mice will get the tumors. So whatever happened back here is a
permanent clone, if you like, sitting there.
But it's not progressing to give tumors.
So this is this famous quotation from Bern Bloom and Shubik
that we all have these latent tumor cells, at least all of the mice in his case,
only demonstrable by subsequent promoting action, which converts them into
morphological tumors. So we went back and
repeated all of these experiments.
And so we did this latency experiment.
We waited up to a year.
And they were absolutely right. To do this, we had the benefit
of knowing what the event is at the initiation stage.
That was characterized back in the 1980s showing that the DMBA,
which is the initiating carcinogen,
binds to adenosine residues, and it causes A to T mutations.
These two different type. These two As can both be mutated.
They both give activating initiating mutations.
So we can use this, and in fact extend this to a mutational
signature for DMBA to find exactly the trinucleotide
signature, which Mike Stratton talked about the other day.
And we can look for that signature in tumors
initiated by this single dose of DMBA.
So when you do that, you see the purple columns here
represent the number of mutations in a tumor. Each column is a tumor.
The SBS DMBA is the trinucleotide signature
for that single dose of the carcinogen.
So some of the tumors have up to 30,000 mutations in their tumor
genomes. Some have relatively few.
Important thing for this slide is this part here.
These are the tumors that came from the delay experiment where you treat and then
you wait for up to a year. Right? So this tumor here has
about 50,000 mutations
that were induced on day one by that single dose of the carcinogen.
And that includes Ras, it includes p53.
But nevertheless, that cell, that single cell, sat there for a year and
didn't actually do anything.
They all required the promoter. So Bern Bloom and Shubik were absolutely right.
The promotion is the rate-limiting step.
These are genetic models of cancer here induced by KRAS
G12D in the skin, and then followed by either
wounding or TPA. So no mutagenic exposures.
And these have vanishingly few mutations, and the only recurrent mutation is this
one here. You don't see any other recurrent somatic mutations in
these tumors.
So all you need is that one mutation plus the wounding or the TPA.
So what I've told you then is that these RAS mutant cells can
persist a long time in the normal skin and not
actually do anything. And those of you who've been following the clonal
competition literature over the years will be aware of some of these papers.
These are from the group of Valentina Greco.
There's also
other groups. Phil Jones and others have
shownThat mutant cells are
removed from normal tissue by tissue damage or by
aging. In their case, the mutant cells get shoved out, and
this is a phenomenon of clonal competition that was
started many years ago in Drosophila, extended to other
developmental model systems. But we have these two apparently opposing
kind of views. One, your RAS mutations are permanent, the other, they
get kicked out by their neighbors.
So we've been using a number of approaches to try and
reconcile these two different types of observations
using these types of assays here,
where we take a normal young epithelium, no obvious
mutations. You have some cells with sporadic mutations.
If you treat with a--
That could be induced by DMBA. It could also be spontaneous, as we'll come
back to later. Then some of these clones begin to expand,
in our case, under the influence of exposure to a promoter like
TPA. So you get these larger purple clones, and they're the
ones that go on and give tumors. But there are all these other mutations in
here. And to find them, we use this technique,
which was developed by TwinStrand.
Jesse Salk was instrumental in getting this
technique going, starting the company.
And Jesse has collaborated on many of these studies.
So the interesting point, I think, which is also relevant to the previous
talk,
these are DMBA-induced mutations.
But we can also have spontaneous mutations in exactly the same tissue,
where all of us sitting here are acquiring spontaneous
mutations all the time. So if one of these spontaneous mutations is
promoted in response to TPA or anything else, then you can
get a red tumor. You could also have alternative promoters.
I mentioned PFAS, but wounding, and there's a whole range of other promoters that
you could think of.
And then you can maybe stimulate the green cells to give you a green
tumor. So we have this variability in the sources of
the mutant cells and how they respond to their environment, and that's the
end result that we're
trying to measure.
So this is using this TwinStrand approach to try to
track some of these events. The top panel here, each
box is one mouse. And so 10 mice in here, these are all the
controls. Some of the mice have mutations in H-RAS,
K-RAS, or N-RAS at codons 12, 13, or 61.
So each box is a little microcosm of RAS mutations.
Some of the mice have no mutations detectable at this level.
Several have well-known mutations.
This one has a K-RAS G12D mutation.
There are some H-RAS mutations, some N-RAS mutations.
So these are spontaneous. I'll come back to that in a second.
When we do one single treatment with DMBA, now we see all these
codon 61 mutations because codon 61 is
highly sensitized to
DMBA because it has two adenosines, both of which are
activating alleles.
So we now find all these new H-RAS induced mutations on
top of the spontaneous ones.
We begin to treat with TPA,
and then we see this explosion of mutations in the codon
61 boxes down here for all of the mice.
And the biggest pink circle is H-RAS Q61L,
and that is the mutation, the clone that gives us the tumors in 90%, more
than 90% of the tumors in this model have that specific mutation.
There are all these other mutations in there that are clonally expanding, but they
don't quite win out. The first tumors that come up have the H-RAS
mutations.
We also see spontaneous mutations, as I mentioned,
and this is what happens if you treat the mice only with the promoter,
not with a mutagen. So there are no mutagenic events, exogenous mutagenic
events here. And what you might see is that
these spontaneously arising clones, these big ones here, are some very
similar patterns.
This is K-RAS G12D.
This is K-RAS G13R. Again, G12D,
G13R, G12D, G13R. So a very common pattern.
These mutations are not random. They're being selected in normal tissue,
and then they respond
in response to the promoter.
But we never get tumors with these mutations in the skin if we keep
promoting. And you can see that here.
This is a rather complex panel. So the main thing is this set
on the left, these are non-initiated
mice, no DMBA, and various treatments with TPA.
Don't worry about this down at the bottom.
So this is kind of treated in one way or another.
This is treated with DMBA first, and then the same kind of
promotion schedules down below. The main point is the H-RAS
Q61L. You see very little going on here.
You treat with DMBA and TPA. These increase very, very
strongly. G12D, we see it responds to the TPA,
but then nothing. It goes away.
K-RAS G13R responds to the TPA in the absence of
DMBA. Even in the presence of DMBA, it goes way up, but
then it disappears between four and eight weeks.
So this set of tumors or mutations going up and then down.
So basically, that's shown here. The green tumors, the green
clones, I should say, are K-RAS G13R driven.
The pink ones are H-RAS Q61L. Without any DMBA,
the G13R goes up and then down.
With the DMBA initiation, the H-RAS goes up and kind of stays up.
The K-RAS goes up and then down and
disappears.And so,
we never get tumors with
either of these KRAS mutations. But what we found was that
in mice that have no HRAS, remove HRAS, and
then do this whole thing all over again, they now get tumors that
have the KRAS G13R. And that's basically the take home
message is in here. If you treat HRAS knockout mice with
TPA for 20 weeks in the usual way, they get very few tumors
compared to normal mice up here.
But when you sequence those tumors,
the benign tumors, 30% of them have KRAS G13R,
and the malignant tumors, even more have KRAS G13R.
So now, when you take away HRAS, it's competing for
targets in some way that we don't understand, so that there's a direct
competition between these clones.
When you remove the selective pressure of HRAS, then the
KRAS ones, which are spontaneous...
Actually, no, I should qualify that.
These ones are spontaneous, and some of these ones are spontaneous.
These sort of funny color ones here, these are
induced by the DMBA, but they're not the canonical mutations that
we normally expect.
So removing HRAS reveals these KRAS
mutant tumors, which we saw actually a long time ago but never
understood, I think, until now.
Now, I have one minute and 50 seconds left.
So I'm going to jump through all of this next session.
The next session was,
I'm notoriously bad at estimating these things, but the next session, a few
slides, is to address the question of why does this happen?
What is the biological mechanism of promotion?
Why do we get this clonal selection?
And basically, the take home message is the immune system is
extremely important.
If we do all of this DMBA TPA stuff with NSG mice,
which have no immune system,
we get very, very few tumors. They just don't get tumors.
And cell cycle is also very low. And I'm going to flip
through to the very last part.
And basically...
Hang on a minute.
We used two different agents to do these twin strand
type experiments. One was TPA, which you've seen,
and one was a compound called RPA, which is very similar to
TPA. It causes the same level of inflammation, the same level
of hyperplasia.
The mice don't like it equally with TPA,
but the TPA gives us this huge clonal expansion.
And this other factor, which causes inflammation, does not give us the clonal
expansion. So two very closely related molecules with very different
biological effects.
And the difference between them that we found so far is in the immune
cells. We do single cell analysis, and the TPA gives us this
big increase in neutrophils, myeloid cells.
The RPA gives us as many overall leukocytes,
but we are missing the monocytes
and the neutrophils. So this gives us a target population to
begin to inhibit, to try to prevent all of this happening, which is the
main goal of the Prominent team, which is funded by Cancer
Grand Challenges. That means studying promotion to
inform prevention. That's the fancy acronym.
So the ultimate goal is to get towards the prevention stage.
And this is
the overall prominent team.
Nuria, the co-leader, is in here. And I need to acknowledge also
Feriel from Nuria's lab, who has done a lot of this work
on the statistical analysis of the clonal
expansions. The other work, mainly Yves
Candebat has done most of the work on the KRAS and HRAS
competitive mutations. And Andrea
has done most of the immunology work.
So I'll stop there if there's time for some questions.
Hello, Alan.
Yes, sir. So we're still back at the
same question. What is it about inflammation that selects
specifically
the expansion of an HRAS mutant cell that's just sitting there?
Right.
So do you have any idea what that might be? Is something... Yeah.
Well, we now know that the neutrophils,
monocytes,
and that signaling pathway is essential,
right? So if we don't have those, we do not get the tumors.
However,
it's much more subtle
than that. As I showed you, we do get some tumors with RPA.
It turns out that most of those tumors that we get with the RPA, that small
number, they do not have the same mutation
as the DMBA TPA model. So
I believe that what many of these different chemicals
are doing, obviously they're causing stress, but they're causing
stress in different ways. Some are causing ER stress.
Some are causing oxidative stress.
And the particular,
some like cocaetic acid induces the same mutation, but it does
that by
inhibiting PP2A. So there are these different mechanisms upstream that
different promoters activate.
But I think they're converging on some biochemical mechanism that
is linked to wound healing, endogenous
processes of wound healing. And we're looking heavily into the role
of ROS, reactive oxygen species, and the factors that control
that, because we know you can demonstrate changes in
mutation frequency by messing around with ROS levels.
And so another question. Thank you.
Different strains of mice, as you're super familiar with, different
strains of mice, genetic backgrounds do not respond as well
to RAS mutations and TPA promotion.
They don't get hardly any tumors,
the B6 mice versus NIH mice. So do you
think that's also related to inflammation in those different strains of
mice?
Yes.
Yes is the answer. We've done many of these same experiments
with
B6 mice, which are much more resistant than other
strains, FVB. We get about the same number of mutations with
DMBA.
Mm-hmm.
We don't see any difference in the mutational signature or the
clonal drivers that we can see.
Mm-hmm.
So I think the mutagenesis part of it is very, very similar.
The promotion part, the clonal expansion you get with just a few
treatments with TPA is much smaller with B6 mice than-
Mm-hmm
... FVB mice.
So the take-home message there is that genetic susceptibility to cancer-
Promotion
... may have more to do-- Well, we knew this all along, right?
Is related to this promotion stage.
Yeah. I would-
Very complex-
I think we're-
... multigenic and dah, dah, dah, dah.
Yeah.
Okay. Thanks.
Question there?
Yeah. We have all these new fancy allele-specific RAS
inhibitors that we're able to use in clinical medicine or in studies.
What do you think will happen if you use a G12D or a G12C in
the presence of just normal aging or these accelerated models?
What's going to happen?
Well, I think there are some big surprises waiting when we do that.
What we see from these experiments is that
HRAS and KRAS are competing very strongly with each
other,
and we think that that's because
HRAS
and KRAS, the KRAS has two different
isoforms, a major and a minor. The minor one is
largely ignored, called 4A. It has the same C-terminus
as HRAS, very similar. So we think they're competing with each other.
When you
remove HRAS, then you're kind of freeing up this
effect of this other isoform from KRAS, and
that we're convinced is one of the major factors in this
changing clonal selection. But it does mean that if you
treat people or mice with an HRAS inhibitor, you
might promote KRAS mutations. If you treat them with--
It's a huge excitement. I think it's $50 billion
bets on the pan-RAS inhibitors, which are beautiful drugs.
People are not cured. They live several months longer, but they're not cured.
But there's going to be huge effects on clonal architecture
by using exactly these drugs. KRAS G12D is one of the most common
spontaneous mutations that we see.
So what's going to happen if you use these inhibitors?
People are already talking about using them for prevention,
but that is going to have, I think, a lot of
consequences down the line.
One quick question and quick answer.
Just when comparing the TPE and RPA single cell that
you did earlier, I was curious if you think that the
monocytes and neutrophils are sort of promoting the tumor growth,
or they're directly interacting with the tumor cells, or if you think it's more
like
they're blocking lymphocytes from
potentially maintaining the tumor or keeping it sort of
small, like small clones?
Right.
I don't know the answer to that yet.
These are very recent data which haven't been published.
What we think, they could be both things.
It could be a direct effect of, for example, neutrophils
generate an oxidative burst. So that feeds into this mechanism
about reactive oxygen and how initiated cells may
respond. But myeloid cells in general, they inhibit
the immune system. They inhibit T cells.
And so if you have infiltrating myeloid cells more generally, then
that can affect the immune interactions with those
clones, which again is something that nobody has really
managed to demonstrate at this level, early clonal
selection.
Great. Well, good. Thanks, Alan.
And next is Jian Karubian.
Thank you for this great opportunity to invite me to talk about
our work. This is in close collaboration with Dr.
Sasha Gulse from Dana-Farber, where we try to understand the germline
determinants of cancer progression using real-world clinical
sequencing data. And this is a really fantastic session that the
discussions have really given a nice introduction of
why we are doing this here. I have nothing to disclose.
So cancer is driven by accumulation and the selection
of somatic alterations. And germline
inherited variants can modulate these processes.
For example, germline BRCA carriers are more likely to
develop a second hit in BRCA in the tumors, and that
leads to HRD deficiency, which is now an
important therapeutic biomarkers.
So understand germline somatic associations not only provide us new
insights into how cancer develop, but also provide
some therapeutic opportunities.
But most of the study in this space has been focusing on rare high-penetrance
variants, and we know that much of the missing heritability
underlying tumor progression is probably lying in common
variants with small effect sizes.
And
my lab is particularly interested in looking at population-level common variants,
how they modulate tumor somatic mutation selection in the tumors
and clinical outcome, and their impact on clinical
outcomes.But to answer these kind of questions, we need a
lot of data. And interestingly, historically, germline
genetics and tumor genomics have evolved as two separate
fields. And as a result, there's a lack of
data with both tumor and normal sequencing at GWAS
scale that can facilitate detecting common variants through
genome-wide association studies.
And if we want to understand their clinical impacts, we
also need to integrate clinical data at
population scale.
So to solve this problem, we turn to real-world clinical genomic
sequencing cohorts. Targeted
panel sequencing is commonly used in clinical practice.
We sequence a lot of patients' tumors, and now this number has
reached genome GWAS scale.
And
now with these
advances in larger models, we can also
automatically extract clinical information and
integrate clinical information with genomic sequencing in this kind of real-world
cohorts.
And to integrate germline information,
in close collaboration with Dr. Sasha Gusev at Dana-Farber and his
team,
we leverage off-target reads. So even though we are only
sequencing a few hundreds of known cancer
genes, we target these genes, but there are a lot of off-target reads, and
these off-target reads sequence random DNA fragments and
randomly distributed across the genome.
So they sequence a patient's genomes at a low depth,
and these off-target reads can capture common
variants, and we can impute missing
variants and reconstruct patients' haplotypes across the genome
using reference
panels with no haplotype structures.
And here we performed a benchmarking
analysis just comparing genotypes from
whole genome sequencing data to MS Impact data, where we
inferred
common variants from off-target reads.
And we can see here that for both tumor-only
sequencing and normal-only panel sequencing, we can achieve pretty
good imputation accuracy. And when we combine multiple
sequencing data from the same patients,
we subsequently increased off-target reads coverage for each
patient. And this really improved the imputation
accuracy, especially when we improved the off-target
reads coverage.
So in summary, we can actually reconstruct genome-wide patients'
common variants and haplotypes through
leveraging off-target reads from these existing
clinical genomic sequencing data.
So now we have a germline somatic and the clinical data
integration. We can start to run a bunch of GWASs on
panel sequencing data, which we thought is really cool.
In this study, we focused on comparing tumors with
certain mutations of interest versus tumors without mutations.
And we performed pan-cancer analysis.
We also performed a cancer type specific analysis.
We used MS Impact data as a discovery cohort.
And you can see here that we can find several interesting
associations, some of them already known.
So we were able to successfully replicate previous associations
and we also discovered a new association and these new
associations can be successfully replicated in independent
cohorts. So here we use a Dana-Farber profile and TCGA
data to replicate our findings. So it's really suggesting
that our approach is robust.
Okay, so just give you an example what we see here.
So this is
through a pan-cancer analysis, we compare tumors with TP53
mutations versus tumors without TP53 mutations.
And then we perform the GWAS
on the panel data from MS Impact and we found that
1q32 locus is associated with
more somatic mutation, TP53 mutations in the tumors.
And you can see that these variants can be mapped to MDM4 gene,
which is a known negative regulator of TP53 so we are very
excited about this. There seems to be a real
relationship between these two genes.
And this association is also consistent across different
type of cancers. You can see that's in breast cancer, colorectal
cancer, pancreas cancer, prostate cancer.
And the association is also consistent across different type of
TP53 mutations, including missense, hotspot
mutations, protein truncating mutations and TP53
LH.
And we also performed a TWAS analysis aggregating
multiple eQTLs in MDM4 gene and we can
see that the
predicted overexpression of MDM4 in the
germline
is associated with more TP53 mutations in the tumors.
And when we conditions on the predicted MDM4
expression, the association between this locus and
TP53 is no longer significant, suggesting that
MDM4 expression may be the mediator of this
locus and mutation association.
We're also collaborating with
my colleagues at
the University of Utah, where they generated a lot of high chip
data in different cancer cell lines and you can see that
these lead SNP in this association can be mapped
to this enhancer promoter loop across
different cell lines and this loop is pretty close to
MDM4So, in collaboration
with colleagues at
MSK,
we performed the CRISPR-9, deleted
the enhancer region of this enhancer and
promoter loop. And
our collaborators tested all the genes in this
locus, and they found that only MDM4 expression was
affected by the deletion of this
enhancer region in this loop, suggesting that
MDM4 expression is potentially the target of this
enhancer.
And the reviewer look at this very excited, and they ask
how these variants may affect patient survival,
metastasis, response to treatments, and makes really, really good
suggestion. And we have the data at MSK,
and we were like,
"Sure. Let's take a look of this."
So we found that this
variant near MDM4 is enriched in patients with
late-stage disease. They're enriched in patients diagnosed as Stage 4
disease and is also enriched in breast cancer
patients with lung metastasis.
And this germline variant
contribution to metastatic risk is appear to be
independent of the TP53 mutation status.
And if you look at TP53 mutant tumor only,
the effect appear to be even stronger, suggesting that these
combined germline effects and somatic
alteration can jointly drive tumor
progression.
And the
reviewer also asked was mutagenesis versus selection.
You guys probably read the paper because these are all the questions that keep
coming up.
So of course, we try to understand, right, it is possible a
germline variance may create this genomic instability that leading
to more
mutations in the normal cells. And it is also possible that these
mutations are already present in the normal cells, and the germline
variant just modulates this selection advantage
to drive the cancer transformation.
So, in this test, we also additionally controlled for
tumor mutation burden and tissue-specific mutational
signatures. We also controlled for environmental factors such
as smoking status. And you can see that at least this
MDM4 TP53 association remain significant,
suggesting that this association might be independent
of mutational processes but maybe play a
role in selecting specific driver mutations.
So what we think happening here is that
germline MDM4 overexpression may lead to
baseline reduction of TP53 activities,
and that really acquire second hit in TP53
and together drive tumor initiation and progression.
And this expands the classic two-hit theory where the second
hit may not necessarily to be in the same gene but can be in a different
gene in the same pathway.
But we also want to note here that this is just
one model that we
see, and there are a lot of other germline somatic association may not necessarily
follow this model.
And even though the MDM4 TP53 relationship is
known, we also see associations in genes that were
not previously known,
have known relationships. So suggesting really, by looking
at both germline and somatic space, we can discover new
gene-gene dependency and hopefully provide more insights into therapeutic
developments.
Now I want to switch gear to talk a little bit about a project that's,
it's not really a project, but it's part of a paper, but it's really analysis that
close to my heart.
We know that patients from different populations, they can
carry different somatic mutations in the tumors.
For example, for lung cancer patients with East
Asian and Native American ancestry, they are more likely to
develop EGFR mutations in the tumors compared to European ancestry
patients. And this
relationship seems to be independent of smoking exposure.
And in prostate cancer,
ERG fusion is more commonly observed in patients with
European ancestry. So our question is, through
these driver GWAS
frameworks, can we
find ancestry-specific germline variants that may explain these
somatic differences that we see between populations?
So in this analysis, we compared ERG
fusion tumors, prostate tumors,
to prostate tumors without ERG fusion.
And this is based on impact panel sequencing.
We found that there's a risk variant
significantly associated with ERG fusion, and this
offers protective effect on ERG fusion.
And this association is consistent
across different ancestry groups.
But if you look at the allele frequency
of this risk allele is actually less common
in patients with European ancestry.
And we performed
statistical mediation test,
and we found that this risk allele linked to ERG
fusion can partially explain the relationship
between European ancestry and ERG fusion, suggesting
that this variant may contribute to
the somatic differences that we see between
populations.To
summarize this work,
I hope I convinced you that we can run GWAS on panels
by leveraging these kind of real-world sequencing data, and we can have immediate
access to a lot of samples. And our pan-cancer
framework identified novel germline somatic associations
that are independent of cancer types, that can be seen across
different type of cancers, across different type of mutations.
And these variants may play a role in promoting
specific somatic mutations, driver mutations
in the tumors. And the fact that the
germline variants can independently influence tumor progression and
metastasis suggests that we should probably rethink about
germline effects when we think about how to detect
or prevent metastasis. And finally, germline
somatic associations can provide mechanistic insights into
why patients from different populations
have different somatic mutation frequencies.
And this also highlight the need to increase diversity from both
germline genetics and somatic studies.
And finally, our approach was successfully
applied to two real-world cohorts, MSK-IMPACT and
Dana-Farber Profile. And we believe that, as I showed, this
approach also work really well for tumor-only sequencing data.
So
we are hopefully really bring this approach to other
institutions' data sets, because these real-world cohorts is
pretty common now in commonly used in clinical practice.
And we really believe that by
meta-analyzing data from different institutions that really can help us
boost the statistical power to detect more association and really
understand what are the missing heritabilities in cancer progression,
metastasis and response to treatments.
I'd like to thank people in my lab, especially Cong Min
and Han Xiao, who are the leading authors for this project,
our collaborators at Dana-Farber, our MSK
colleagues helping with the functional validation, and our friends from
University of Utah helped with the HiChIP data.
This project is funded by AACR Genie POM, got a
lot of really great collaborations with Genie POM people.
And this is my contact. I'm looking forward to discussions and
hopefully we can collaborate on this. Thank you.
Yeah, floor's down.
Great talk. Super interesting. I was wondering, in those
individuals that have increased expression of MDM4, can you actually see that they
have different patterns of P53 mutation in that maybe they're
more likely to have only heterozygous mutations and the other allele
intact or maybe weaker mutations?
With kind of like an interesting idea being that maybe they don't need the
full destruction.
Yeah, this is a great question. We try to look at TP53 LOH
but calling loss of heterozygosity is a little bit
challenging in panel sequencing data, but we do see
there's still association with LOH.
So I think in the tumors you probably still need a second hit, like complete
loss of TP53
and the fact that it's pretty consistent across different hotspot mutations
in TP53 and protein-tron getting mutations in TP53.
So I don't think it's really targeting a specific TP53 mutation.
I was kind of expecting maybe we need less TP53 in the
tumors but I don't think that's the case here,
but it is worth looking into.
Yeah, just following up on this theme, one of the
observations that was made with mouse models where
you can plan in advance what your germline genotypes are going to be.
You can make F1 hybrid mice that have different alleles
and that allowed the community to
map multiple tumor susceptibility loci in mice or tumor
resistance loci in mice,
and it turns out that if you look at tumors from these mice, most
often, even though we don't know what the gene is,
some cases we do, the
susceptibility allele gets amplified
in the tumors or the resistance allele gets lost or deleted in the tumors.
So looking at patterns of LOH with polymorphisms,
that linked up very nicely with the directionality of
susceptibility and resistance alleles.
So I think you just mentioned that you couldn't really do that in your panel but-
We can
... is that a possibility?
I think calling a copy number from paneling data is still a
bit challenging, but I think we can guess that as part of...
Actually, we have a project similar to what you're describing, looking at these
known risk alleles, whether they are amplified or deleted in the
tumors and to understand their role in
the tumor evolution.
Yeah.
But I think this is like poor man's version and we are using existing
data, try to get a signal from what we have right
now. But if we can really do a whole-genome sequencing, paired or tumor
normal, like at a population scale, and that's the future.
So one quick question from me, because
you have very strong data on the MDM4 and TP53,
but you started with-General analysis unbiased.
So how many other hits do you see below?
I know that with more power you will see more, but what is your sense at the
moment?
I think there are actually a lot, and
the association can follow different
rules, different mechanism, different models.
We are not detecting as many as we wish, like we're looking at hundreds
or thousands of associations. But we see the
association that we replicated. We are very confident about what we are showing
here that all replicated.
And the power is still, in the discovery cohort, we have
50,000 cases, which is large, but it's still if you
slice by cancer type or even some mutations are more common
in certain cancers, some of the rare mutations.
So we're still a little bit underpowered.
And actually, when we
include the additional samples, because, another thing with these kind of
real world data is that they keep growing.
And like two years later, we are including the more samples, and we
found, oh, the previous signals that were a little bit weak in the original
discovery cohort now is genome significant.
So I do think that increasing sample size and the
multi-institutional, cross-institutional work is going to really help boost the
power.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you very much.
So next presentation is by me.
Okay, so I'm
going to talk about cancer driver mutations in normal tissues and its relation
to cancer risk. It's very much related to the three talks that we
already heard.
I don't have conflicts of interest.
This is the basic question I'm going to pose today.
So we know that there are carcinogens from epidemiological
studies. We know there are agents that increase cancer risk, and also lifestyles
and risk factors.
And the question is: how do they do it?
Together with Alan Balmain, Paul Brennan, Yves Candiba, and Abel
Gonzalez-Perez, we have been thinking about this question, and
we have this paper that was
out a few days ago. This is a review paper in which
we thought about this question of carcinogens through the
tumor promotion, initiation and promotion model.
And the title is "Tumor Promotion Through the Lens of Evolution." And basically
what we say is that initiation is cells that acquire cancer
driver mutations. This is random events, and at the end, you have some of these
cells. Then you have tumor promotion, that is that some of these cells
with specific mutations in a specific environments may acquire
a positive selection, clonally expand, and some of these clonal
expansions may relate to increased cancer risk.
So from this concept, it emanates that carcinogens may
act in two different ways.
Some may be mutagens, and certainly we know that
some of them are, and basically increase the mutation rate.
But from work from Alan and other people, we know that many
carcinogens are actually not mutagens.
So we have to think how do they work and how to study them.
And
they may not create new mutations, but
change the rules of selection in the tissue, leading to clonal expansions
of mutated cells, also increasing the number of cells.
And actually, this can be exponentially increasing the number of cells
with driver mutations, and this way increase cancer risk.
So what I'm going to do in the talk is to give you an example of
the two parts. And this is Axel
Rosendahl-Huber, who did this work in my lab, and this is
a work that we are finishing. So the question
is how many
cells or how likely it is a cell in one of our tissues to receive
a cancer driver mutation by random mutagenesis, right?
And this is going to be different depending on exposures, because if it's the lung
of a smoker, it could be higher than if it's a lung of a non-smoker, for example.
And I think that this is the first time that we can start answering these questions
with very accurate numbers, and that's thanks to data that has been
generated in other labs,
that is whole genome sequencing from
normal cells in different donors, in different tissues.
It's mostly data from Peter Campbell's lab and other people at the Sanger.
And we have, for a number of donors, whole genome from colon
crypts, from lung stem cells, and from
blood cells. Right? And now we know the mutation burden, and
we know the distribution of mutation in these cases.
And you can very quickly see that, for example, in the case of smokers, of
non-smokers, you would have around, this is around 2,000, 3,000
mutations in whole genome, and this number is much increased in a
smoker.
And to answer the question of how many cells may
harbor driver mutations in our tissues, or what is the
probability of every mutation to occur, we may be tempted to do
the very simple back of the envelope calculation and say, "Okay, we have
3,000 mutations along the genome, and we have this number of bases in
the genome, so this is the probability." And this would be completely wrong,
because the mutations are not distributed
equally along the genome, right? They have very high preferences for
some regions that are more likely to mutate and some genes than others, depending
on expression, chromatin openness, histone marks, and many other
things. And also at trinucleotide level, you know about
mutational signatures and basically different
mutagens have very strong preferences for certain
sites. So we need to take this into account to be able
to do the estimation of the mutation probability per
site.And this is what Axel has done.
He has developed MutRisk that estimates the probability of each mutation to occur
in normal tissues, and this accounts for the overall mutation rate in that
cells, in that tissue, in that donor,
mutation rate variability per gene and per mutation type.
And then once we have this MutRisk model, we can put a probability
of any site in the genome to mutate in that person, in that
tissue.
And this is applying this to TP53
amino acid positions. And you can
very quickly see in a colon of a donor, you can very quickly see that there is a
huge inequality, so that there are some sites that have a very high
probability to mutate and some sites that have very low probability to mutate.
Right? So if you throw random mutations due to these mutational processes in a
tissue, you are going to have some mutations that you see very frequently and in
many cells, and some mutations that are very rare.
And now that we have a probability per site,
in a particular tissue,
to want to know how many cells have this driver mutation, we just
have to multiply by a number of cells,
right? And we have many cells in our body, 36
trillion cells. But instead of multiplying by all the cells,
that you can very easily see that many mutations are not going to have any
importance if the cell is going to die next day and not give progeny.
So the important cells at risk are the stem cells that
are long-lived and give progeny, and they can transmit the mutations
and lead to these clonal expansions that we have discussed.
So these are the numbers that we are using for lung basal stem cells, bone marrow
stem cells, and crypt stem cells.
And then we can use this probability of a cell of
a specific mutation to occur in a cell,
multiply it by the number of cells in that tissue.
And for every donor, we can, for example, calculate how many cells have
TP53 driver mutations.
We can do this for any mutation or any gene.
And in this case, this is a donor of 79 years old.
Eighteen
thousand mutations, 18,000 cells will have,
TP53 driver mutations just by neutral random mutagenesis.
Numbers are different in lung,
because we have many more lung basal stem cells, and there are
important differences between non-smokers and smokers.
And for example, in this case,
this person will have around 1.5 million
cells in the, stem cells in the lung with TP53
driver mutations. These are huge numbers, right?
So you wonder when you see these numbers why we don't have cancer every day.
But we'll get to that.
Numbers are very different in blood, and the reason is because the pool of
hematopoietic stem cells is much more reduced, is about
100,000
cells. So then in a donor like 76
years old, we'll have about six cells with TP53 driver
mutation in the blood.
As I said, we can do this for any gene,
and we can also do it for combinations of mutations.
So we may wonder, how likely it is that a cell
just by random mutagenesis without any selection, will
acquire
all combination of mutations that lead to colon cancer.
For example, two APC driver mutations and one KRAS driver
mutation. And then you realize the probability is actually very, very
low,
right? So only 45 individuals
out of one million people will have at least one cell with
this mutation
if we don't invoke any clonal selection.
And this is very different to the real incidence of colon cancer with
exactly this combination of mutations.
Okay, so there is this big gap that
cannot be explained by just thinking that cells are there seated
waiting for mutations to occur, and when the right combination occurs, this cause a
cancer. So we need to invoke clonal selection,
of intermediate mutant states, for example, clonal selection of APC
mutation.
So the summary of this part is millions of cells, with driver mutations in
our tissues, but it also
is different depending on the tissue.
And that combinations of multiple mutations, for example, in colon
cancer, are unlikely to arise just by chance without
clonal selection in, of intermediate mutant states.
Okay, so going back to this slide that I showed before,
there has been a lot of work on carcinogens as mutagens,
for many years. There has been much less work, and
it's much more difficult to handle this question that
is carcinogens as promoters. And as Alan has shown
in his work, many carcinogens are not mutagens.
So we really need to study that. This is the topic of the Cancer Grand Challenge
PROMINENT, and our proposal is to measure selection in normal
tissues to understand promotion.
And just a note that selection is the
result of not only the mutation, right?
The mutation is important, but it's the right mutation in the right cell with the
right cell state or cell phenotype in the right tissue
microenvironment. So when we measure selection, we are seeing
the result of the interaction between these three factors.
And what we are doing is to measure selection in the normal tissue
of different people and compare people that are exposed and non-exposed to a
carcinogen or comparing
the normal tissue at different time points before and after an intervention.
I'm going to give you only one result of the paper that is already
published, that is the study of normal bladderIn different
people,
asking the question of the two main risk factors of bladder cancer,
which are that males have a four times higher incidence of
bladder cancer than females, and smokers have a higher incidence than
non-smokers. So then our question is, in the normal
tissue, are there differences already in the clonal selection between males and
females and between smokers and non-smokers?
So to do that, what we do is a broad sampling of the
normal bladder urothelium at autopsy.
All these donors didn't have any bladder cancer, so this is normal
bladder. And when we do this cytobrushing of about
two centimeter squares, we
expect to have many microscopic clones.
So what we want to do is very deep sequencing,
and we use duplex DNA sequencing that Alan already introduced because it's a
way to get error-corrected sequencing.
So we can identify very rare mutations, even if we see them in only
one molecule, and trust that they are real mutations.
This is work in collaboration with Rosana Risques and Raquel, Anabel,
and Ferriol are the
PhD students from my lab who led all the analysis.
Okay, so when we do that, we had these 45 different donors.
We did very deep duplex sequencing in the normal bladder, and we
identify a huge amount of mutations.
What you see on the left is the number of mutations in these genes that we
targeted with the duplex.
And what you see on the right is the number of mutations that we have in
Intogen on bladder cancers, and these include 892 bladder
cancers.
The reason why we have many more mutations is because we have many clones.
When you think about the tumor, it's one clone.
So in one clone, you may have one TP53 mutations or two TP53 mutations,
but not more. When we sample normal tissue, we see many
clones, and we can identify actually in one sample, many TP53
mutations. And then you may ask, "Okay, Nuria, but these are maybe
random mutations."
So that's exactly what we do. We measure very carefully positive
selection.
So by simulating the neutral mutagenesis, we can
estimate how many mutations you expect to have in a gene.
For example, this is RBM10. How many truncating mutations we expect
to have in RBM10 in the bladder of this donor?
Forty-six. How many truncating mutations we observe?
1,641. So there is a huge increase, and this huge
increase can only be explained if truncating mutations in
RBM10 provides a selective advantage and clonal expansion.
So at the end, we have many more reads and molecules with
these mutations. Same with missense mutations, they are also increased.
In the case of TP53, we also see this
increase in the number of missense and truncating mutations.
So actually, the vast majority of mutations that we observe are
driver mutations
in these genes.
And then we can ask
the question of if there are differences between males and females.
With this study, we can measure DNDS, so the
excess of truncating mutations in each sample.
And then these are males, and these are females, and we can see that there is
a very important difference in the DNDS values between
males and females.
And I show you here TP53, because TP53 has also a strong
selective advantage, but we don't see a difference between males and females.
And then we do the proper analysis, accounting for different ages,
smoking, even BMI, and other factors to
just ensure that or see if the difference is really
related to being male or female or something else.
And for these three genes, the difference
is very important, even after correcting for all these confounders.
The other result that we found is that we identified TERT promoter
mutations, the two main TERT promoter mutations that we also
see very often in tumors that activate telomerase.
We also find them in a normal bladder with a very
strong signal of positive selection, but it's mainly only
in smokers. So smoking is changing the
environment of the bladder. It's not necessarily creating these mutations.
We know that, but it's promoting the expansion of
clones with TERT promoter mutations in the normal bladder.
And this, you can think how this may relate to cancer risk,
because more than 70% of bladder cancers have TERT promoter mutations.
So summary of this part .
This is a cost-effective way to study clonal selection, this brushing and
very deep duplex sequencing, and we can compare different individuals.
And for example, we see a stronger positive selection in males in these three genes
and TERT promoter mutations leading to these clonal
expansions in smokers.
So I just want to finish again with this slide.
I'll show you the example of bladder.
We are doing a similar thing as part of PROMINENT for other tissues
. And just also to remind you that the selection that we are measuring is the
result of these three interacting things, and we also want
to understand how tissue microenvironment and cell phenotype change
upon
exposure to some of these carcinogens.
Last slide, thanks to people who did the work.
I think I mentioned most of them. I want to also mention Abel Gonzalez Perez, who
is co-leading this work with me.
Funding, PROMINENT, of course. And if you want to use the
tools and the methods and the protocol that we developed,
this is available in protocols IO.
So thanks for your attention
.
We have time for questions.
Hi, Nuria. Fantastic as always.
What dazzles with their absence is the natural variants.
So the natural variants, they're in the cell already.
So listening to these combinations of mutations that are necessary to occur in the
one cell, so that propagation can occur,
cannot one imagine that a risk allele may play the role of this
somatic mutation you're lacking in this cell to start
growing? In other words, the interaction between naturally occurring variants
and those randomly occurring
somatic variants that get the chance to propagate
into clones.
Yeah. Natural occurring variants, you mean endogenous mutational
processes?
SNPs.
Ah, SNPs, germline. Yeah. So this relates to what the presentation by
Jian, that, yeah, exactly. She gave a very good example
of how the natural variation
between us may also shape that. So we are focusing a bit more
on how the exposures and the carcinogens or
lifestyle change that. But yeah, the normal
and the SNPs may also.
I really like the first part, which I hadn't heard before.
And my question was, one of the predictions to be made is
that the discrepancy between
the incidence of cancers with specific mutations and numbers of
mutations and the baseline random mutagenesis model should
be decreasing as the self-renewal of the tissue
drops. So
have you tried to look at, for example, for the brain, where Chris
Walsh and Peter Park have pretty decent single-cell data
too, whether the
random mutagenesis model is a better explanation just
because the clonal evolution part is less likely to play a huge role
in post-mitotic brain?
Yeah. So I think that it's going to be very different in different
tissues, depending on that. First, on number of stem cells,
mutation rate, but also how likely they are cycling,
right? Because if they, like bladder or
esophagus or colon or blood, they cycle very
often, they have a much more likelihood to clonally expand, and
other tissues may not. Right? So I think it's the combination of
all these things, and also the combination of the structure of the tissue.
For example, if you think about blood, all the cells can compete
between them because they are mixed.
If you think about colon, they cannot, right?
The structure of the tissue is a big determinant of the probability of these cells
to clonally expand or not clonally expand because they cannot compete easily
between them. They are geographically separated.
So in brain, yeah, it's interesting to think because it's not
dividing, but
so every tissue is going to be a different story, and yeah, hopefully we can
analyze other tissues when data is coming.
Great presentation. Just curious, in order to use
the protocol app you mentioned,
what type of
specimen can we use? Can you
extract information from just regular blood sample,
serum sample, or is there some requirement for it?
Yeah, basically, you need
broad sampling of many clones, and this is where the value is
to doing duplex sequencing, like for example, brushing of a
epithelium or a blood sample. We are doing it in blood.
We just take blood sample, extract DNA, and do duplex
sequencing.
You need enough DNA, but it's not a huge requirement, and
ideally, that the quality of the DNA is not very degradated,
for example.
But then,
the protocol, what it's doing is duplex sequencing, is sequencing the two
strands of one DNA molecule, and this is the way that we can know
that the mutation is not introduced by PCR amplification or
sequencing, because that could happen only in one strand and not in the two at the
same time, which may happen, but it's very unlikely.
Hi. Thank you for a really good presentation.
My question is regarding
the work that you've shown regarding the exposure to risk factors.
So I think that canonically, the way that we
integrate exposure to risk factors into these studies is by relying on
clinical annotations and everything, and I was wondering, what are
your thoughts on how reliable that is to actually determine the
effect of these risk factors on this positive selection or negative selection
of different clones? And whether there would be any better
measures, more molecular measures, for example.
I know that mutational signatures are not available for all risk factors, but-
Yeah
... do you think that simply relying on clinical annotation is enough?
Yeah. Well, you need very well-annotated cohorts to be able to even start
doing that, and that's one of the things that we have, thanks to the World Health
Organization and IARC. Paul Brennan has very well-annotated cohorts,
but they also have some limits. For example,
so what you're saying is, if you would be able to have these
exposures directly from molecular determinants,
and in some cases you have, like smoking, you can ask the people, or
you can see the mutational signature of smoking, or colibactin exposure
is one exposure as well that we don't ask people if they have
colibactin because they even don't know, but we see it molecularly from the
mutational signature. So yeah, whenever you can derive it directly
from the data,
it's even better sometimes. Yeah. Good point.
Thank you.
Okay, so if we can ask,
yeah, Camila, Alan, and we have few more time for
questions, and there is at least one question for Camila in
the-Oh.
Do you want to stick around or?
Yeah. So let's only ask the question for Camilla, because I'm looking at the time,
and it's basically over. But in the AML cohort, you
saw clonal hematopoiesis drivers as neutral.
What is the prevalence in your control cohort of CH?
And then we
finish.
So I should first clarify, they weren't neutral.
They had a carcinogenic effect of about 10.
So that means that
a lineage that contains a TET2 or DNMT3A driver mutation
is about tenfold more likely to found a cancer than a non-lineage.
I will say, I think in that AML plot, these carcinogenic effects are
a little bit
overestimated, and I unfortunately didn't have time to go into
it. But the big difference between the esophagus plot that
I showed you and the AML plot was that in the AML setting,
we didn't have enough
non-malignant blood from current AML patients
in order to do the analysis. So the control data set
is just normal blood, and the mutations are coming
from essentially clonal hematopoiesis.
Not clonal hematopoiesis as defined by CHIP, meaning most of these clones
were from a deep sequencing study that looks at much smaller
frequencies than what is defined as CHIP.
But
that was in fact the control there.
There were people without AML and who were unlikely to get AML.
The interesting thing is that if you do
the comparison to pre-AML blood, you get the same ranking
of driver genes, but the carcinogenic effects are attenuated, which is kind of in
line with the idea that there are fundamental
differences in the overall composition of the blood in people
who do or do not have cancer.
But yeah, I hope that clarifies it.
Yeah, it does.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Then we close here the session.
Thanks everyone for attending, and thanks for the speakers.